♪
>> Greg: SUNDAY SOME OLD GUY
SPEWING F-BOMBS.
>> THIS GUY SHOULD NOT BE
PRESIDENT, PERIOD.
>> AND WHEN YOU SAY THAT
FOLKS ON FOX COME AFTER YOU.
I REMEMBER THE TONIES HE GOT
UP THERE AND CURSED.
>> [BLEEP]
>> YOU KNOW THIS IS CABLE SO
IT'S NOT AN FCC VIOLATION
BUT IT IS STILL SUNDAY
MORNING.
>> SORRY.
>> Greg: TRIGGERED BY OUR
NATION'S HALL MONITOR BRIAN
STELTZER ASKING HIM ABOUT
FOX NEWS FOR SOME REASON.
THE HOST ACTS DONE AS IF HE
DIDN'T SEE IT COMING MAN WHO
TALKS BIKE A ONE MAN NAVY.
>> THIS [BLEEP] IDIOT IT IS
THE PRESIDENT.
>> THE GUY IS A [BLEEP]
FOOL.
OUR GOVERNMENT TODAY WITH
THE PROMPTING OF OUR BABY IN
CHIEF.
[LAUGHTER]
>> [BLEEP] I CALL HIM.
>> Greg: THAT'S SOME
RELIABLE SOURCE HAVE YOU GOT
THERE THIS IS WHAT MOMS CALL
BAD LANGUAGE OR PRODUCERS
CALL GREAT TV.
THE PLAN GET AN IRRATIONAL
FIGURE AT PEAK DERANGEMENT
AND GO INTO SNAPPING CABARET
FOR THE CHRONICALLY
OBSESSED.
LIKE A KID WOULD PULL
WHEELIES ON OLD MAN
JOHNSON'S FRONT YARD CRACK
AND HOLD A SPATULA CHASING
YOU AROUND IN HIS OPEN ROAD.
THAT'S THE DENIRO CNN
BUSINESS MODEL IN A NUTSHELL
MONEY FOR NOTHING AND CLICKS
FOR FREE.
REAL STORY OF YOU WHO
ACCUSATIONS OF TRUMP'S NUTTY
BEHAVIOR ALWAYS ENDS UP WITH
THE ACCUSERS ACTING NUTTIER.
DENIRO CALLS TRUMP CRAZY AS
HE GOES CRAZIER.
ADAM SCHIFF CALLS TRUMP A
LIAR AS HE MAKES UP QUOTES.
DEMS TALK ABOUT UNDERMINING
INSTITUTION THAT'S TRY TO
UNDERMINE AN ELECTION.
WHEN ASKED FOR REASONS WHY
TRUMP SHOULDN'T BE
PRESIDENT, ALL BOBBY HAD
WERE PUT DERING F-BOMBS.
HIS RESISTANCE HAD RUN OUT
OF SCRIPT.
ANOTHER ROLE WITHOUT
DIALOGUE SO HE HAD TO
IMPROVISE.
BY HAVING IT ON "THE FIVE"
IT QUADRUPLED THEIR
AUDIENCE.
CONGRATS FOR THAT ONE MINUTE
YOU HAD A HIT.
SO, DANA, SHALL I QUOTE
SCOTT ADAMS?
>> Dana: YEAH, I WAS
THIRSTY.
>> Greg: HE CLAIMS THAT
BECAUSE WE HAVE ENTERED A
NEW PHASE WHERE NOT LIKING
TRUMP IS JUST A LIFESTYLE.
SO YOU ARE A LIFESTYLE
RESISTER.
>> Dana: YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE
TO HAVE A REASON.
>> Greg: WHY, WHY?
F HIM, F HIM.
>> Dana: WHEN YOU RUN OUT OF
WORDS AND CAN'T EXPLAIN
ANYTHING.
THEY THINK YOU ARE TOO DUMB
TO UNDERSTAND.
IF YOU HAVE TO ASK A
QUESTION THEN CLEARLY YOU
ARE NOT SMART ENOUGH TO
UNDERSTAND WHY HE SHOULDN'T
BE PRESIDENT.
THAT'S IN HIS MIND.
THE WEIRD THING BUT THE
F-BOMB STUFF IS THAT HE IS
CLEARLY DOING IT ON PURPOSE.
HE HAS ENOUGH SELF-CONTROL,
I WOULD IMAGINE, TO NOT DROP
F-BOMBS BUT THEY ARE DOING
IT FOR EFFECT, AS IF IT
WORKED.
WHO ELSE DID THAT RECENT
HAVE ANY BETO O'ROURKE?
REMEMBER, HE IS OUT THERE
DROPPING THE F-BOMB
EVERYWHERE TO THE POINT ABC
HAD TO SAY BY THE WAY, NOT
GOING TO BE ALLOWED ON OUR
DEBATE STAGE.
NOT GOING TO ALLOW THAT WE
MIGHT JUST DO IT ANYWAY.
I JUST WONDER ABOUT ROBERT
DENIRO BECAUSE IT DOES SEEM
LIKE HE IS EITHER PLAYING
HIMSELF OR A CHARACTER OR IT
COULD BE JUST THE SAME THING
NOW.
>> Greg: THIS IS A ROLE.
THE RESISTER IS THE ROLE
NOW.
AND HE IS COMFORTABLE IN THE
ROLE.
>> Dana: STAR NOT GUILTY
>> Greg: I WILL SAY, THIS
DONNA, I AM PRO-SWEARING.
I DON'T KNOW WHY WE HAVE TO
BE SO WORRIED ABOUT THOSE
WORDS.
AND MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE I
DON'T HAVE KIDS.
I FIND SWEARING TO BE A
VALUABLE THING.
>> Donna: YOU KNOW, I SPENT
MOST OF MY CHILDHOOD AND I
WOULD SAY ALMOST HALF OF MY
ADULTHOOD GOING TO CHURCH ON
SUNDAY CONFESSING TO USING
SWEAR WORDS.
SO I TRY TO AVOID THEM
ALTHOUGH I HAVE BEEN KNOWN
TO MAKE COMPLETE SENTENCES
OUT OF SWEAR WORDS.
BUT NOT ON THIS SHOW.
THIS POTTY MOUTH STUFF, I
DON'T THINK IT'S GOOD TV,
EMILY.
I THINK IT'S RUDE.
IT'S OFFENSIVE.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE TO -- I
SAID THIS WEEKEND DON'T TAKE
THE BAIT.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT WAS
TWEETING OUT THINGS, CALLING
DEMOCRATS SAVAGES.
I SAID DON'T TAKE THE BAIT.
BE BEST.
I ALWAYS USE THE FIRST LADY,
YOU KNOW, #BE BEST.
WE ALL TRY TO BE AT OUR BEST
WHEN WE ARE DEALING WITH
THESE TOPICS.
>> Greg: COULD POTTY MOUTH
BE A MEDICAL CONDITION?
>> Emily: TOURETTE'S.
[LAUGHTER]
THERE IS SOMETHING TO BE
SWEARING FEELS GOOD AND
BLOWS OFF STEAM.
THAT'S USUALLY PRIVATELY AND
THERE IS OBVIOUSLY THE
STRONGER ARGUMENT FOR IT IN
THE NATIONAL CONVERSATION IN
PUBLIC DISCOURSE WE WANT YOU
TO BE ABLE TO USE YOUR WORDS
AND HAVE THAT SPECIFICITY
AND RISE ABOVE IT ESPECIALLY
FOR THOSE RUNNING FOR
OFFICE.
BOBBY D. DOUBLE DOWN AND
INSTEAD OF APOLOGIZING
LITERALLY HIS RESPONSE TO
BRIAN SAYING SO, YOU KNOW,
FOR YOU LIKE KIND OF
UNLEASHING THAT TIRADE THAT
WAS HIS RESPONSE TO THAT.
HE DOUBLED DOWN.
THAT BEING SAID, HE IS A
LARGER THAN LIFE CELEBRITY.
NOTHING WILL EVER TOUCH
BOBBY D.
>> Greg: REALLY?
I THINK HE MIGHT BE TOUCHED
NOW.
>> Donna: PROMOTING THIS
MOVIE THE IRISH MAN?
>> Jesse: I THINK EVERYBODY
SHOULD SEE IT BECAUSE THEY
SHOT A BIG SCENE ON MY OLD
STREET IN THE WEST VILLAGE
IT LOOKS AMAZING AND HAS JOE
PESCI IN IT AND ANY OF THOSE
GREAT ACTOR IN THOSE GREAT
GANGSTER MOVIES.
I DISAGREE WITH ALL OF YOU.
HE IS OLD, HE DOESN'T CARE.
HE IS RICH, OBVIOUSLY TRUMP
DRIVES HIM CRAZY.
I DON'T THINK IT'S LACKING
SELF-CONTROL.
I THINK HE IS LETTING IT ALL
HANG OUT THERE.
WHO CARES?
SAY WHATEVER HE WANTS TO
SAY.
I DON'T THINK IT'S THE
CLASSIEST.
>> Greg: I COULD CARE LESS
ABOUT THE SWEARING.
I COULDN'T COME UP WITH A
REASON.
YOU RUN INTO A LOT OF PEOPLE
LIKE THIS THAT WHEN YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT THEM JUST TELL
ME AND THEY GO ARGH AND THEY
RUN AWAY.
>> Jesse: WHAT DO YOU HAVE
PEOPLE WHO WATCH FOX NEWS I
DON'T CARE WHO CRITICIZES
ME.
>> Dana: I ADMIRE THAT I
MEAN I'M KIND OF SENSITIVE.
>> Donna: BUT I SUPPORT THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENCY
REGARDLESS OF HOT OCCUPANT
IS.
TO HAVE SOMEONE, YOU KNOW,
USE THAT WORD IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENCY, I HAVE A DECENCY
STANDARD.
I MAY DISLIKE.
>> Jesse: HE WASN'T SAYING
THAT ABOUT THE PRESIDENT.
THAT WAS A COUPLE WEEKS
BEFORE.
>> Greg: I HAVE INDUSTRY
STANDARD.
>> Donna: I NEED TO GO TO
CONFESSION WITH YOU.
YOU HAVE TOO MUCH FOR ME TO
DEAL WITH.